wenn sie etwas unbedingt wollen wenn
etwas richtig wichtig ist
überlebenswichtig möglicherweise sogar
was machen sie dann
sie klemmen sich doch tag und nacht
dahinter dieses problem zu lösen
überlassen das nicht anderen verlassen
sich auch nicht auf die ansagen von
irgendjemandem sondern packen das an
sind richtig hartnäckig all das war
unsere regierung beim thema impfen
offenbar nicht das wissen wir jetzt seit
einigen tagen aber was genau ist das
schief gelaufen und vor allen dingen wer
trägt die schuld an diesem desaster das
klären wir jetzt die richtigen fragen
bei bild willkommen im neuen jahr die
richtigen fragen hierbei bild heute mit
bayerns ministerpräsident markus söder
live zugeschaltet genauso wie aus der
nähe von münchen aus feldafing nämlich
die langjährige bundesjustizministerin
sabine leutheuser-schnarrenberger und
hier im studio bei bild der
spd-generalsekretär lars klingbeil ihnen
allen einen schönen guten abend und
danke fürs kommen oder zugeschaltet sein
das war ein wunderbarer schneetag in den
meisten teilen deutschlands so auch hier
in berlin und eigentlich dachte ich
dieser ski oder rodel winterfeld aussah
dann aber doch in einigen landesteilen
ganz anders aus nämlich so zum beispiel
in winterberg in nordrhein-westfalen
volle pisten dort leere pisten so hatte
ich es eigentlich verstanden in bayern
markus söder heißt dass das neue bayern
ist der harz und ist das sauerland und
ist das rothaargebirge oder haben dies
falsch verstanden dort die da heute auf
der piste war nun das entscheiden die
jeweiligen bundesländer wir haben uns
immer für einen sehr konsequenten kurs
entschieden natürlich kann die natur
jeder genießen mit der abstand gehalten
wird wir haben dabei bewusst entschieden
als echte skifahrer nation wie wir
bayern sind nicht dieses risiko
einzugehen wir haben gesehen was in
österreich war mit dem öffnen der
chefposten
es gab dann relativ schnell überlastung
und musste wieder geschlossen werden
gehört von ähnlichen szenen ist auch in
deutschland meinen rat ist bei all
diesen maßnahmen die wir treffen wir
müssen jetzt konsequent bleiben wir
müssen es gerecht machen und gerecht
heißt für alle das gleiche
nur so haben wir eine chance von diesen
hohen infektionszahlen wieder
runterzukommen aber erkennbar sind die
bayern einfach vernünftiger weil die ehe
auf ihren landeschef hören oder ist der
landeschef der strenge und deswegen
gehen die nenner wir auf die piste aber
in bayern nicht so ich will mich jetzt
an der auseinandersetzung zwischen
syrien und den laschet nicht beteiligen
aber ich glaube dass wir sehr stolz sein
können dass ganz viele menschen in
deutschland sich verantwortungsvoll
zeigen das ist ja der allergrößte teil
der mitmacht der darauf achtet finde man
kann den menschen nicht verweigern das
jetzt bei dem wetter mal vor die tür
gehen dass sie spazieren gehen dass sie
wenn der schnee da ist mit den kindern
schlittenfahren
aber herr söder hat völlig recht ist
muss nach den regeln funktionieren die
gerade helfen dass wir durch diese
pandemie durchkommen abstand halten
aufeinander achten masken tragen da wo
es notwendig ist und da wo es auch
geboten ist und da gab es schon einige
bilder die mich echt gestört haben die
letzten tage und ich bin froh dass jetzt
auch maßnahmen ja auch in nrw
anscheinend ergriffen werden dass sie
sprechen dann kann man nochmal ganz
kurzen blick darauf werfen es kam dann
nämlich tatsächlich später an der
einsatzhundertschaft und hat das ganze
dort aufgelöst hier wie gesagt in
winterberg in nordrhein westfalen da
sind dann die rollenden familien von der
piste gehackt worden so zu sagen
sabine leutheuser-schnarrenberger für
sie völlig normal nach diesem ganzen
chor ohne ja solche bilder
einsatzhundertschaft auf der piste in
der freien natur und schickt die leute
nach hause
so ist es halt nein das ist natürlich
natürlich nicht normal
denn eigentlich will man ja den schnee
genießen ich kann das verstehen dass
junge menschen gerade raus wollen aber
wir müssen uns jetzt an die regeln
halten
sonst kommen wir aus diesem lockdown
nicht raus und wir wollen bald wieder
mehr freiheiten haben und dazu müssen
wir erst noch mehr uns beschränken
es ist aber sollte das die ausnahme
bleiben mit den hundertschaften auf der
piste herr so da eine frage an sie als
chef als ministerpräsident wenn sie
wollen dass sich jeder mitarbeiter
wirklich etwas hält das allen klar ist
hier geht es um alles es gibt viele
wichtige dinge zu beschließen aber wenn
es wirklich um alles geht wie machen sie
das ihren mitarbeitern klar ich glaube
zunächst mal ist klar das ist
einheitliche regeln gibt die jeder
versteht und wir müssen auch so
kommuniziert werden
ich denke wir haben das jetzt in
deutschland endlich erreicht
wochen das war nicht immer so wir hatten
ja lange zeit die endlose debatten auch
untereinander auch der minister weil sie
den mit dem bund der bund mit uns was
ist jetzt der richtige weg wie viel
welche dosierung muss man es hat sich
gezeigt dass zögern am ende nicht
belohnt wird im gegenteil es braucht
klare regeln es braucht vernünftige die
jeder wahrnehmen kann wenn man schon
quasi ein juristisches staatsexamen
braucht und wir regeln zu verstehen dann
wird es sicherlich schwieriger insofern
glaube ich so wie frau leutheusser
schnarrenberg und da klingen weil ich
sagen haben wir jetzt eigentlich eine
gute basis die sollten jetzt auch nicht
vorzeitig aufgeben
wir haben keine verlässliche
einschätzung darüber wie sich
weihnachten und silvester
infektionsgeschehen ausgewirkt hat wir
können nicht sagen was mit dem
urlaubsrückkehrern in familien
heimkehren ist und deswegen wäre das aus
meiner sicht nicht richtig jetzt
vorzeitig zu locken sondern einen klaren
satz zu sagen der heißt wir müssen den
lockdown leider ich sage das
ausdrücklich dazu leider weil es eine
einschränkung ist bei der bis ende
januar verlängert
das heißt das ist ja eine nachricht
dieses tages es dauert leider die
meisten von uns werden vermutet haben
deutlich länger als bis zum 10 november
lars klingbeil liegt auch schon das ist
im grunde der können wir schon fast ein
strich drunter machen jetzt geht es nur
noch ein bisschen um das vieh und aber
bis ende januar bleibt erst mal dicht
also ich glaube dass wir gar nicht
anders können in der jetzigen situation
erfordert das angesprochen die zahlen
sind nach wie vor nicht so wie wir alle
erhofft haben ich glaube da gab es
einige schließe mich da ein die sich
erhofft hatten dass die november
maßnahmen dass die zu anderen zahlen
führen aber wir wissen nicht was die
mutation aus großbritannien bedeutet wir
wissen nicht was über die feiertage sich
entwickelt hat wir wissen nicht wie das
mit rückkehrern aus dem ausland ist also
es sind alles unsichere faktoren und ich
da wird das schlimmste wäre doch jetzt
wenn wir immer wieder hin und her kommen
wenn wir jetzt lockern und dann in drei
vier wochen sehen wir müssen wieder
maßnahmen ergreifen wieder an den
dritten lockdown also lieber jetzt
längeren atem haben konsequent sein was
nachvollziehbar dass auch beschließen in
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und
dann klarheit für die menschen diesem
land haben ist das ein erstmal dann bis
ende januar herr söder oder ist das ein
bis ende januar
es ist alles was wir derzeit tun immer
nur auf sicht wir können ja nicht etwas
prognostizieren dass gerade gerade im
angesprochen
es ist auch nicht ganz klar was ist mit
dem mutationen die wir aus
großbritannien haben sind offenkundig ja
bereits in deutschland welche wirkung
haben sie führt das zu einem anderen
infektionsgeschehen und ist bleibt schon
die hoffnung dass wir die maßnahmen
länger gehen dass auch wir die zahlen
deutlich senken können das ist so und
wir haben ja auch noch die hoffnung
impfstoff leider nicht in dem maß wie
wir uns das wünschen würden von der
menge her aber es ist eine hoffnung um
insbesondere die lebensgefährliche
situation jetzt in den alten und
pflegeheimen
doch deutlich zu verbessern insofern
gilt es jetzt bis ende januar aber es
gibt nie garantien es weitergeht es
hängt auch alles nach wie vor von jedem
einzelnen von uns ab je mehr mitmachen
je mehr sich daran halten desto besser
darüber wollen wir jetzt streiten
natürlich auch über das was in sachen
impfen schief ging in den letzten tagen
und wochen das hat viele über die ja
eigentlich sonst ruhige
weihnachtsfeiertage sehr sehr verärgert
hat da ihre analyse nach herr söder der
mut gefehlt vorher bei der bestellung
die führungsstärke am ende auch gefehlt
also das kann aussicht hier in
deutschland nicht einfach beurteilt
werden aber klar scheint eindeutig dass
die ankauf strategie der europäischen
union nicht optimal war insbesondere
vergleich zu anderen regionen der welt
damit sind england schon über eine
million geimpfter wir haben in anderen
regionen israel sagt sie sind bis märz
mit allem durch erkennbar ist es in
europa an das nicht nur in deutschland
übrigens deutschland liegt das sogar
noch besser wir haben das in den
niederlanden italien sehr schleppender
impfbeginn bei uns wird in den
bundesländern was geht verimpft aber man
kann allein an der etwas unsicheren
situation erkennen dass die hälfte der
impfdosen zurückgehalten werden muss die
man bekommt die hälfte muss
zurückgehalten werden weil nicht sicher
ist ob man für die
auffrischungsimpfungen zwei wochen noch
die genügende lieferung bekommt es zeigt
ja es ist eindeutig aus meiner sicht zu
wenig bestellt waren
das kann man sicherlich festhalten und
möglicherweise auch auf die falschen
hersteller gesetzten das hat ja biontech
vor wenigen tagen auch gesagt was das
interesse europas an ihre bestellung
getroffen hat insofern jahre sind
sicherlich fehler gemacht worden
das hilft uns aber jetzt auch nicht wir
müssen gucken wie wir die situation
jetzt verbessern
ja das stimmt vor allem er in der
sendung auch darüber sprechen trotzdem
lohnt es einer festzuhalten auch die
chefin
dass der leopoldina hat die an den tagen
gesagt ganz klar die verantwortlichen
haben wir großes versagen verursacht
dann muss man auch die verantwortlichen
einmal benennen asyl hat jetzt die eu
genannt hat sie uns gesagt da ist zu
wenig bestellt worden wer sind die
verantwortlichen der klinge berlin ihren
augen ich glaube da macht man sich das
zu einfach wenn man einfach auf die
europäische union zeigt natürlich ist
das richtig dass wir den weg der
europäischen beschaffung noch gegangen
sind da will ich garnicht
internationalismus zurück wollen ja aber
trotzdem muss man sich ja fragen wer
betrifft denke ich die entscheidung also
vor von der leyen als
kommissionspräsident in welche rolle die
bundeskanzlerin
der deutsche gesundheitsminister und
wenn ich jetzt in dem interview von
beyond ex-chef lese dass er sagt er hat
der europäischen union sogar zu einem
zeitpunkt wo wir wussten dieser
impfstoff wirkt und der wird schnell
fertig sein
hat er der europäischen union oder der
kommission mehr impfstoff angeboten
das hat die europäische union abgelehnt
warum hat deutschland dann nicht
bilateral dazu gekauft viel mehr als das
der fall war dann wären wir heute einem
ganz anderen zustand dann hätten wir
viel mehr verhindern können und ich
finde den satz will ich noch sagen wir
verlangen den menschen viel ab das haben
wissenschaftler 24 stunden sieben tage
die woche dran gearbeitet wir können
stolz sein dass dieser impfstoff aus
deutschland kommt die ärzte die
pflegekräfte alle arbeiten auf hochdruck
seit monaten wir sagen den menschen
bleibt zu hause wir schließen geschäfte
und die aufgabe die wir erledigen müssen
ist dass wir diesen impfstoff beschaffen
und dass die impfstrategie richtig ist
und da sieht man jetzt dass wir
teilweise chaotische zustände haben und
ich finde das ist kein zustand mit dem
uns zufrieden geben können was mich
stört ist dass gerade auf den finger
europäische union oder den
gesundheitsminister auf die
bundeskanzlerin ist muss jetzt geklärt
werden was ist da eigentlich falsch
gelaufen und dann kommt die hauptfrage
wie können wir jetzt schnell wieder
abstellen aber wie war ihrer meinung
nach sie haben gerade die frage gestellt
wer hat da was entschieden wie war ihrer
meinung nach oder ihrer ihrem eindruck
nach die rolle der kanzlerin in dieser
frage
ich habe sie bisher nicht wahrgenommen
also wie entspannen ist derjenige der
erst mal dass verhandelt hat dass es so
richtig der gesundheitsminister hat die
weitgehende kompetenzen auch bekommen
das ist auch wichtig dass wir diesen weg
gegangen sind ich finde er hat nicht
genug impfstoff besorgt man hätte in dem
moment wo bei antec gesagt hat die
europäische kommission wir können noch
mehr liefern europa lehnt das ab hätten
wir als deutschland bestellen müssen ja
das hätte tun müssen das ist nicht
passiert und die kanzlerin habe ich die
letzten tage zu diesem chaos nicht
vernommen
müsste sich dazu äußert sich dazu äußern
und vor allem muss jetzt mithelfen dass
wir die situation kennen es gibt ja
großen frust in diesem land gerade ich
habe viele menschen ist man bei kreis
die nicht wissen wann sie empfehlen ich
habe erlebt dass die ehrenamtlichen die
impfzentren aufgebaut haben wirklich
großer dank für das was da in den
ländern geleistet die brauchen sich
mussten jetzt muss jetzt losgehen
er ist wieder hier wird die rolle der
kanzlerin angesprochen leute kommen auch
gleich dran haben auch schon gelegt an
der stelle können sie das aufklären wir
haben ja im moment wie er sozusagen als
deutschland im moment die eu
ratspräsidentschaft das heißt wenn wir
mit dem finger nach brüssel zeigen
zeigen wir eigentlich den finger nach
berlin
nee das ist nicht so über die operative
verantwortung liegt natürlich bei der
kommission liegen hat ja gleich gesagt
die kommission hat zu wenig bestellt
also es ist klar dass es an der
kommission liegt wie die umstände waren
warum man so entschieden hat das lässt
sich aus meiner sicht schwer
nachvollziehen
das müssen andere beurteilen aber fakt
ist es ist zu wenig bestellt waren ja
zum teil auch von den falschen
herstellern was mich gewundert hat es
scheint auch sehr eine große preis
debatte gewesen zu sein
was mich wundert wenn man überlegt was
für enorme summen wie in deutschland
ausgeben müssen für überbrückungshilfen
für entsprechende maßnahme da wäre das
deutlich günstiger gewesen zu impfen
klappt der gesundheitsministerien sparen
ist da rund um die uhr im einsatz er hat
übrigens im vergleich zu anderen ländern
mehr bestellt was auch dazu führt dass
es selbst innerhalb europa schon
debatten gegeben hat ich habe gelesen
dass ist der kritik ab dass deutschland
mehr bestellt hat und an ein impfchaos
ist es übrigens nicht das ist ein
quatsch denn es wird ja alles was da ist
ordentlich verimpft das problem ist der
impfstoff selber ist noch nicht
ausreichend vorhanden grund wer zum
beispiel auch notwendig dass die
zulassung zu anderen impfstoffen die in
anderen ländern der welt bereits
getroffen wird indien beispielsweise
großbritannien dass wir auch die
zulassung natürlich mit sicher der
prüfung auch beschleunigen denn auch ein
zweiter im stoff allein entlaste die
situation genommen
ich will noch mal bei dieser
entscheidung er sogar ganz kurz bleiben
die entscheidung dass im eu-rahmen am
ende zu organisieren ist ja hier
getroffen worden hier in berlin dies in
bestimmten zeitpunkt 2020 eben getroffen
worden
vermutlich im kanzleramt kann man jetzt
sagen das war eine fehlentscheidung das
hätte man jetzt zurückblicken klar
nachher ist man schlauer aber das hätte
man rückblickend besser nicht gemacht
dass man das über brüssel
plett organisieren lässt er die
entscheidung das ist in europa passiert
ist in europa getroffen und es gibt ja
auch gute gründe dafür gibt gute gründe
dafür
von der marktmacht europas
beispielsweise mit einer großen
bestellung bis zu machen also die
ausgangssituation spricht nicht dagegen
die umsetzung ist das problem für die
umsetzung ist nach meiner auffassung
jedenfalls werde nicht die
bundeskanzlerin verantwortlich sondern
die zuständige eu-kommissar dass das
dann entsprechend abwickelt und umsetzt
und da muss man sicherlich die fragen
platzieren aber die
grundsatzentscheidung wie kann man
treffen verstehe natürlich und glauben
sie mir mich ärgert dass auch weil in
der tat wir haben 99 impfzentren in
bayern
wir impfen glaube ich im moment relativ
gut was geht im vergleich zu den anderen
bundesländern wobei alle sich die mühe
gegeben da gibt es jetzt keine keine
rankings die man gern veröffentlicht
wenn ergibt sich jeder mühe und tut was
er kann
wir müssen auch ehrlicherweise sagen wir
stellen auch fest dass die
impfbereitschaft nicht an einigen
stellen so hoch ist wie sie sein aber
nicht bei den menschen beispielsweise in
den alten und pflegeheimen aber bei den
dortigen pflegekräften spüren eine große
zurückhaltung das heißt wir müssen im
stoff besorgen müssen aber gleichzeitig
noch dafür sorgen dass die
impfbereitschaft sich deutlich erhöht es
sind glaube ich dass wir auch in einer
zweiten runde
wenn wir jetzt gerade die pflegeheime
durchgekämpft haben auch nochmal
vorbildfunktionen brauchen die sich
impfen lassen um diese ganzen feld muss
die nach wie vor ex meistern mit denen
man wirklich immer wieder überraschender
weise konfrontiert wird was da alles
gesagt wird um die auch zu kontern und
dabei helfen wir gerne als vorbild voran
dabei dabei helfen gerne herr söder ein
punkt trotzdem festgehalten sie sagen
die kommission also hier eindeutig die
verantwortung bei den kommissionschefin
auch ursula von der leyen frau
leutheuser wie geht da ihre analyse wie
gesagt bei der eu-kommission bei der
zuständigen kommissariat natürlich
sollten entweder an der bundesregierung
ist auch wäre oder ein anderer ton ist
es genau in der tat der redakteure etwas
schreibt unser name ja aber natürlich
gehört doch zum meinungsbildungsprozess
ganz selbstverständlich dass die
bundesregierung entscheidend während der
eu-ratspräsidentschaft beteiligt ist die
bundesregierung hat ja zu rechnen
ganz verschiedener länder mit italien
frankreich und so weiter begründet um
den prozess in der eu voranzubringen und
ohne eine aussage wie viel großen mann
in deutschland braucht auch gerade in
welchen zeiträumen ist doch nicht
bestellt worden in der europäischen
union von der kommission also natürlich
eine aktive beteiligung der
bundesregierung das ist auch der normale
weg nicht das parlament aber ohne die
mitgliedstaaten geht da ja gar nichts
nachher bestellt die kommission
verhandelt verträge aber natürlich
müssen die länder sagen was sie haben
wollen
unter teile ich die einschätzung söder
hat recht zu wenig bestellt auf die
falschen impfstoffe vielleicht gesetzt
die es ende des jahres kommen und es ist
ja interessant dass über impfchaos jetzt
innerhalb der bundesregierung spricht
der koalitionsfraktionen geredet wird
ich nehme es hier vor ort so war dass
die altenheime warten darauf dass die
nächsten dosen kommen mit impfstoff wir
haben im landkreis dahme ich zu anfang
mal 100 dosen gehabt dann kamen noch ein
paar dazu also hier ist eine ganz große
erwartungshaltung es geht um leben
impfen heißt lebensschutz und deshalb
ist das so entscheidend dass einige
leute saniert dass eine frau leute sagen
ich will das noch einmal weiter geben
also da weil ich auf die auf das motiv
auch zu sprechen kommen möchte warum
sind diese fehler entstanden denn man
hat ja ganz lange gesagt es geht darum
menschenleben zu schützen ausgerechnet
bei dieser einen sache bei der ganz klar
war das schützt auf jeden fall
menschenleben da sagt die chefin eben
der leopoldina
daher hat man eben da war menschenleben
offenbar dann nicht mehr so wichtig ist
ein harter vorwurf war das zu fahrlässig
war man da fahrlässig verhungert das
nicht funktioniert warum hat man der
falsche entscheidung getroffen oder war
nicht genügend hinterher in der zeit 20
20 also zum einen hoffe ich doch sehr
dass die investigativ abteilung
von bild läuft es da noch aufdecken wird
weil er glaube ich die informationen
noch deutlich besser wenn in brüssel was
da alles war da gehe ich davon aus dass
wir den nächsten tage von ihnen das
sicherlich ein bisschen noch mehr an
fleisch bekommen darüber was und wie das
abgelaufen ist mal abgesehen davon aber
zum zweiten dass das auch machen kann
nicht so wahnsinnig viel bringt sondern
ich finde den einsatz jetzt der stadt
findet zum beispiel die
produktionskapazitäten zu erhöhen
deutlich ein gutes zeichen ist und auch
die zulassung eines zweiten impfstoffes
sehr wichtig allein das würde die
situation deutlich und massiv verbessern
ist wie sie auch in anderen ländern der
fall in denen die anderen impfstoffe
zugelassen werden also ich glaube wir
müssen jetzt zweigeteilt arbeiten des
eines ich glaube die fehleranalyse
relativ offenkundig man hat ja auch
beispielsweise auf falsche hersteller
gesetzt macht gedacht sanofi können das
besser das ist übrigens auch kein
problem dass man sich breit aufstellt es
war nicht so bestimmten zeitpunkt auch
nicht ganz absehbar
wer die besten chancen hat deswegen
hätte man sich auch so breit wie möglich
aufstellen müssen und so viel wie
möglich im übrigen kauft man damit auch
nicht anderen etwas weg man hätte das
wenn es zu vieles auch abgeben können
mir macht die größte sorge neben der
medizinischen fragen die frau
leutheuser-schnarrenberger völlig zu
recht diskutiert völlig zurecht auch die
wirtschaftliche frage wir werden wenn es
uns nicht gelingt im nächsten halben
jahr quasi den impf prozess komplett
abzuschließen und ehrlicher weiß schon
bis märz deutlich mehr zu haben und
besser zu werden werden die im
internationalen kontext als europäer
nicht nur ist deutsch als europäer
deutlich zurückfallen denn das sieht man
auch in china und anderswo
dort wird mit dem krone fortschritt auch
gleichzeitig ökonomische dominanz
arbeitet und darum ist es sowohl im
gesundheitlichen als auch im
wirtschaftlichen interesse möglichst
schnell und möglichst breit zu finden na
klar die länder die als erstes fertig
sind mit dem impfen die können als
erstes wieder aufmachen wir haben vorher
auch darüber mit dem chef des
sachverständigenrates der
wirtschaftsweisen sozusagen gesprochen
mit lars feld und auch mit ihm haben wir
gesprochen über die verantwortlichkeit
dieses im desaster
es kann eigentlich nicht sein dass wegen
feiertagen und dieser phase zwischen den
jahren wie das so schön heißt die impf
aktivität reduziert ist
andere länder können das auch besser
organisieren als wir offensichtlich und
ich glaube das ist eine aufgabe für die
ministerpräsidenten ist das besser zu
organisieren beziehungsweise für ihre
gesundheitsministerin und minister und
das hier doch deutlich mehr hätte kommen
müssen
man sieht ja wenn die informationen so
richtig weiter gegeben werden dass eine
ganze reihe von impfdosen angekommen
sind in den ländern die derzeit noch
nicht verimpft werden
das hätte man also dieser zeit deutlich
besser organisieren können wenn nächsten
freitag schon die nächsten dosen von
bayern tag angeliefert werden können
der wirtschaftsweise sagte jetzt mal
ganz so ist es nicht lag nicht nur an
der beschaffung an der fehlenden sondern
es wird halt auch nicht genügend
verimpft in den bundesländern ihre quote
ist tatsächlich ja noch ganz gut in
bayern aber auch die ministerpräsidenten
tragen da eine erhebliche verantwortung
sagte er
ja ich glaube dass er sagt ja selber und
schwenkt seine aussage ein nach den
informationen in dem vorliegen
und ich möchte diese information einfach
nochmal auch quasi wie diesem format
erweitern noch einmal die hälfte der
dosen darf gar nichts fremd wird die
hälfte muss zurückgehalten werden weil
man nicht weiß ob für die
auffrischungsimpfungen zwei wochen
getroffene zwei impfungen um einen
schutz zu erreichen
ob überhaupt lieferungen kommen das
zeigt auch wie instabil die situation
ist hinzu kommt übrigens noch das auch
nicht alle impfdosen sofort in einem
schwung versetzt werden sondern es ist
gibt daran in bestimmten
altenpflegeheimen leider bei einigen
eine zurückhaltung da müssen die weiter
vermisst werden also ich glaube die
länder und die impfzentren arbeiten auch
haben auch an den feiertagen gearbeitet
das ist nicht das problem
das problem ist der impfstoff um das
noch mal zu ergänzen eine kleine aspekt
der wurde auch öffentlich dokumentiert
an einen tag kam am morgen die nachricht
dass in der nächsten woche also jetzt in
der stadt finden woche kein impfstoff
gebe da keine und dann kam am nachmittag
wieder eine mail
es gebe doch impfstoff man sie eine
andere vor also da gibt es noch vieles
was auch bei uns verbessert werden kann
aber ich kann es nur noch mal sagen die
ärztinnen ärzte die pflegerin pflege in
den impfzentren die ehrenamtlichen wurde
vorhin angesprochen die machen was geht
und impfen was kommt okay sie müssen
jetzt mit dazu beitragen dass das image
desaster aufgeräumt wird sozusagen dass
wir schneller impfen dank herr söder sie
haben einen anschlusstermin deswegen
ausnahmsweise früher hast du ich danke
herzlich für die schalte nach bayern
danke ihm erklingen weil wir haben jetzt
schon das thema internationalismus
angetastet das war ja der vorwurf dass
jeder der sagt moment mal die eu macht
das schlecht wir müssen da mit
deutschland einen eigenen weg gehen dass
der dann ein nationalist ist ist es so
nein wir sind den europäischen weg
gegangen und noch mal das stelle ich
auch nicht in frage dass das der
richtige weg war aber man muss sich doch
schon fragen warum sind eigentlich
andere schneller als in die europäische
kommission also warum geht das schneller
diese frage ist absolut berechtigt und
wir
dürfen auch fragen aber warum ist das
denn so etwas sagen wir brauchen ja weil
ich einen oder island dinge lassen sie
mich den satz noch sagen und und es ist
die frage warum wenig bilaterale
verträge abgeschlossen haben noch mal
wenn europa ablehnt und sagt wir wollen
biontech nicht weil die osteuropäer das
nicht wollten das konnten wir alles
lesen die franzosen das nicht wollten
dann war doch trotzdem das angebot haben
das ist bei mir der moment wo ich sage
da hätten ihren spar noch die
bundeskanzlerin handeln müssen und sagen
müssen dann bestellen wir für
deutschland und diese fragen werden
gestellt werden die müssen von beiden
beantwortet werden wie dieses im chaos
bei der bestellung bei der verteilung
wie das geklärt werden kann das sind
berechtigte fragen aber der wichtigste
punkt für mich und so will ich auch den
schritt nach vorne gehen ist ja wie
kommen wir da raus wenn wir gerade
erleben und das hat er so richtig gesagt
jede woche gerade die wir im lock down
sind kostet wirtschaftlich wahnsinnig
viel milliarden
jede woche entscheidet über leben und
tod jede woche entscheidet auch
langfristig gesellschaftlich was
passiert wenn schulen zu sind wenn kitas
zu sind wenn soziale kontakte fehlen und
deswegen glaube ich ist es doch das
richtige dass man jetzt erwartet dass
hier entspannen und die bundeskanzlerin
die pharmaunternehmen an einen tisch
holen dass man guckt kann man
kooperations verträge schließen kann man
schnell an die produktions gehen
vielleicht ist das etwas was zur chefin
sache werden muss dass merkel sich jetzt
hinter dieses thema wirklich dahinter
klemmt und auch sagt ich kümmere mich
jetzt darum dass es schneller geht aber
ich gebe mich nicht damit zufrieden dass
wir das als deutschland nicht erreichen
können also diese nationale
kraftanstrengung die wir im jahr 2020
ganz oft hingekriegt haben sie muss es
jetzt auch bei mir man hätte ja so
erwartet als bürger als journalist aber
eben auch als bürger als einfacher
bürger jeder in deutschland soll bis
1000 mal gehört in den vergangenen tagen
dass genau das längst passiert wäre dass
man nicht permanent mit den firmen auch
sprechen mir spricht mit den chefs der
film und genau das längst schon
organisiert hat weil das die wichtigste
frage im moment ist wie kriegen wir
schnellstmöglich den impfstoff nach
deutschland ich kann ich habe vor jedem
der da am kabinettstisch sitzt wirklich
ein riesen respekt auch vor den
ministerpräsidenten was im jahr 2020
alles organisiert wurde was gelaufen ist
also wirklich hochachtung vor allem was
passiert ist aber das ist der zentrale
punkt wir haben das ganze jahr 2020
haben wir den menschen gesagt wenn der
impfstoff da ist dann wird es besser und
jetzt stolpern wir sehen dieses chaos
rein und das ärgert mich auch weil mir
häufig die argumente fehlen jetzt zu
sagen warum soll man eigentlich warum
soll man nämlich davon ausgehen dass
jetzt alles gut ist also es geht jetzt
auch um das vertrauen und wenn wir davon
reden wie viele leute lassen sich ein
schimpfen dann ist das gerade der
entscheidende punkt an dem menschen sich
überlegen machen sie das oder machen sie
das noch einmal letzter sprung zurück
versprochen hat die kanzlerin ihren
meinung nach damals rücksicht auf ihre
rolle als eu ratspräsidentin genommen
war das wichtiger als möglicherweise
dann die frage ob in feldafing bei frau
leutheuser in nürnberg bei herrn söder
oder bei ihnen den niedersachsen ganz
schnell geimpft
das weiß ich nicht also ich kann es
einfach nicht beantworten weil ich sie
bisher mit der frage impfen nicht
verbunden habe weil ich von mir keine
äußerung dazu kenne
aber das muss jetzt geklärt werden
allein das ist ja verrückt eigentlich
bauleiter sah ja bis heute verbindet
klingbeil die kanzlerin überhaupt nicht
mit dem thema impfen
das ist schräg also ich verbinde frau
merkel natürlich schon mit dem großen
engagement gegen die pandemie
fortzugehen aber mir scheint ja dass
sein kabinett gar nicht geredet wird
klingbeil erwähnt zu recht den
federführenden minister herrn spahn auch
die kanzlerin aber es gibt ja auch ein
vizekanzler es gibt mehrere spd minister
im justizbereich ganz entscheidend ja
wird er im kabinett nicht darüber
gesprochen so wundert mich sehr
kann ich mir überhaupt gar nicht
vorstellen und es ist richtig erklingen
bei wir haben leider ein impfchaos die
hotlines um den termin in einem
impfzentrum auszumachen
bräche komplett zusammen es gibt kein
online registrierungssystem was einfach
mal flächendeckend greift die
bürgerinnen und bürger warten dass sie
rauskommen aus dem lockt ein weil sie
hoffen dass bis ende januar durchgesetzt
ohne ende und jetzt erfahren wir am 8
januar kommenden paar tröpfchen und dann
nochmal am 18 januar und das ist ja
nichts im vergleich zu dem was israel
und anderes macht und dann ist es ganz
schwierig motivation bei den bürgerinnen
und bürgern zu erzeugen wirklich auch zu
sagen sie wollen sich impfen lassen
und das ist so wichtig und das muss viel
stärker auch in einer motivation
kampagne befördert werden sonst laufen
wir nicht nur in einen impf desaster
wir laufen insgesamt in ein corona
desaster
und da wird das jahr 2000
21 dann schlimmer werden als alles was
wir 220 erlebt möglicherweise ist da
schon reichlich porzellan zerschlagen
worden mittlerweile frau leutheuser auch
noch mal an sie die frage waren da im
herbst 2020 oder etwas später
zuständigkeiten und harmonie in der eu
möglicherweise wichtiger als die impfung
vor ort das kann ich auch nicht
beurteilen weil ich nicht dabei aber sie
haben eine meinung dazu
natürlich hängt alles mit allem zusammen
und ich kann mir schon vorstellen
angesichts der zahlreichen offenen
punkte die es in der eu gab rechtsstaats
mechanismus flüchtlingsfragen natürlich
auch impfstoff erwerb der haushalt in
durchzukriegen die fonds ganz wichtig so
und da wird man am ende wie das immer in
der eu ist die pakete schnüren
ich habe es nie anders erlebt und da es
leider anscheinend wenn das so war das
paket impfstoff nicht so prioritär
gewesen wie es notwendig wäre
sonst würden wir nicht mehr bei
astrazeneca oder noch mehr bei sanofi
millionen 57 millionen impfdosen
bestellen
die war in einem jahr vielleicht auf dem
tisch liegen haben weil das wäre ja
eigentlich noch schlimmer als das nicht
gekonnt haben also wenn man es nicht
konnte dann kann man am ende immer noch
verzeihen aber wenn man sich entschieden
hat im vergangenen jahr
man wollte das auch nicht man wollte den
vermutlich schnelleren weg gar nicht
gehen also das ist doch ganz einfach
aufzuklären die nächste woche die
ministerpräsidenten sitzen zusammenhang
fünften da kann ja ganz klar
frau merkel für die bundesregierung auch
mit für aufklärung sorgen damit sich
nicht weiter weiter auch irgendwelche
gerüchte entwickeln oder
fehleinschätzungen was uns ja auch
letztendlich nicht weiterbringt und wir
wollen ja das ist nach dem 31
januar eine bessere perspektive gibt wir
können doch nicht sagen in zweifel
machen wir halt im februar auch noch so
weiter wir brauchen andere perspektiven
hat die bürger und den besseren lebens
und bei der sitzung diese woche muss das
zentrales thema sein die aufarbeitung
des desasters erklingen bei definitiv
also ich meine das ist nun etwas was die
letzten
tage die menschen massiv beschäftigt hat
wo ganz viele fragen aufgetaucht sind
und ich erwarte dass die runde der
ministerpräsidenten gemeinsam mit der
bundeskanzlerin genau diese frage auch
klärt und wir danach wissen was schief
gelaufen aber wir vor allem auch den
blick nach vorne an das ist glaube ich
das zentrale dass wir wissen kommen wir
irgendwie gemeinsam aus dieser situation
raus und können wir was tun welche
konkreten auswirkungen das hat vor allen
dingen in den altenheimen das haben sie
teilweise schon benannt aber das will
ich ihnen noch einmal zeigen anhand
eines konkreten fall ist hier aus berlin
nämlich mit der schauspielerin katy
karrenbauer die uns jetzt zugeschaltet
ist schönen guten abend frau karrenbauer
sie haben genau leider einen solchen
fall in ihrer familie nämlich mit ihrem
papa mit vater dieter der 88 jahre alt
ist wie sie mir vorher gesagt haben der
im altenheim hier in berlin lebt und der
hoffnung auf impfung hatte warum hatte
frau karrenbauer die runde
gesundes neues jahr ein bisschen schade
dass herr söder ist ende fragen hätte
ich natürlich dass reichen wir im
zweifel nach afrika in bar ganz genau
in einer altersresidenz ihr seit
anderthalb jahren und ich muss
vorausschicken dass das überhaupt einen
fehler gemacht hat es hat also bis mitte
diesen jahres überhaupt keinen einzigen
fall gegeben insofern kann man davon
ausgehen dass die hygienemaßnahmen dort
eigentlich sehr gut funktioniert haben
nun hat am mit bitte diesen dezembers
und letzten dezember gab es zwei corona
fälle und corona verbreitete sich
irrsinnig schnell und mein vater sitzt
jetzt in einem hotspot am 27 sollte er
geimpft werden und das tolle an ihm ist
hat sofort gesagt als es um den
impfstoff geht ich bin dabei ist die
impfung sofort her damit
er hatte dann wirklich also an diesem 27
seinen termin aber es kam niemand
und am 28 war dann klar es gibt einen
großen ausbruch im heim und jetzt sind
mein vater mitten im hot spot der ist
nach wie vor negativ auch heute negativ
getestet aber ich frage mich natürlich
und das fragen sich viele angehörige die
mit sicherheit auch schon in den
impfstrategien mit drin waren und die
auch schon gegeben werden sollten wo ist
der impfstoff jetzt warum ist niemand
ins haus meines vaters gekommen warum
hat man nicht einfach raus geholt um ihm
den lebensrettenden tipps zu geben und
wer jetzt schon eine woche geimpft das
ist ich finde das ist ohne worte und die
menschen die in altenheimen sind ich
betreue hier mein vater schon etwas
länger und habe viel einblick in die
heime die sitzen da und war darauf und
bekommen dann gesagt ja du warst du auf
der liste aber jetzt fuß
und das finde ich ganz ganz schwierig
bei einem mann ab merken dass seine
energie nachlässt also nach 22 jahren
betragen alleine auf dem zimmer sitzen
mit dem versprechen dass der impfstoff
kommt wenn ich das eine tragödie und
zwar für alle angehörigen dies betrifft
eher klingbeil einmal vielleicht haben
sie ansatzweise zumindest eine antwort
für die sind ja eigentlich unglaublichen
fall der papa von frau karrenbauer hat
schon den impftermin der will sich
impfen lassen unbedingt der hat das
glück dass er eigentlich einer der
ersten ist in berlin weil er in einem
heim ist das verimpft jetzt kommt der
chor ohne ausbruch in diesem heim und
das ist der grund weswegen er der noch
gesund ist nicht geimpft wird
es tut mir furchtbar leid ich kann das
nicht erklären gerade und weil ich ich
bin niedersachse ich habe ähnliche fälle
da sage ich gerne gleich was zu bei mir
auch aus dem heimatland
ich kann versprechen und zusagen dass
ich gerne mit der berliner politik
kontakt aufnehmen und dass ich in
erfahrung bringen warum diese
entscheidung genauso getroffen worden
aber verstehe erstmal die emotionalität
und die tragik und das ist ein bisschen
noch das was ich vorhin gesagt habe wir
haben den menschen über monate gesagt
wenn der impfstoff da ist dann wird es
besser und jetzt scheint es hier noch
eine situation zu geben die noch mal
wieder zum verhinderten blockieren führt
und das ist nicht gut und da geht
vertrauen lieber klingbeil ich nehme
hier dabei muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
tun sie das bitte weil er sitzt negativ
getestet er wird jeden tag getestet er
ist noch negativ aber uns allen ist doch
klar dass der vater von fliegern die ihr
die letztes geben und völlig am rande
der verzweiflung sind aber eben auch
cupid patienten betreuen im haus das er
dort in einem hartz iv und sitzt und ich
ihm nicht erklären kann warum er das
zimmer nicht mehr verlassen darf und das
tue ich seit 22 tagen
aber ich merke und es geht um einsamkeit
es geht um so viele viele
begrifflichkeiten aber vor allem wo ist
der rettende impfstoff und ich sage
ihnen ganz ehrlich ich setze schon jeden
abend da und sage mache liegt was tue
ich eigentlich ist das was ich tue
wissend dass mein vater gesund noch dort
sitzt aber sich jederzeit infizieren
könnte ist das nicht unterlassene
hilfeleistung und das werfe ich im staat
vor
wer übernimmt dafür die verantwortung
wenn mein vater jetzt eher krank und
stirbt ist dass frau leutheuser ist das
unterlassene hilfeleistung juristisch im
juristischen sinne denke ich wird das
strafrechtlich wohl nicht so bewertet
werden aber es ist natürlich von der
ganzen auswirkung und von dem wie es
wahrgenommen wird ein unterlassen der
politik wirkungsvoll zu agieren denn es
geht nicht eben nur darum am grünen
tisch innenministerium konzepte zu
zeichnen sondern entscheidend ist doch
was passiert mit den menschen vor ort in
den heimen und sie haben es ja
geschildert ich kenne das auch aus
vielen schilderungen wo eben die
einsamkeit die verzweiflung da ist
wirklich alternativlosigkeit um sich
greift und dann die perspektivlosigkeit
irgendwo greifbar wird
und von daher brauchen wir eben mehr
impfstoffe also mit so ein paar dosen wo
man noch nicht mal jetzt in den
altenheimen bei einem besuch durch ein
altersheim durchkommt ein pflegeheim
durchkommt weil man nicht genug dosen
hat das ist glaube ich das was zermürbt
und was dann auch zu so einer
psychischen und emotionalen belastung
führt und deshalb nochmal auf von mir
aus es ist so wichtig dass die regierung
alles auf die beine stellt da kann man
jetzt nicht sagen das wird schon wir
haben noch ganz gute entscheidungen
getroffen muss nachgebessert werden
nachgelegt werden
das heißt vielleicht können wir
tatsächlich in dem fall der klingbeil
ist als generalsekretär und natürlich
nicht zuständig für das altenheim in
berlin aber er hat glaube ich eine ganz
guten draht zu berliner kollegen
angefangen beim regierenden
bürgermeister der dort möglicherweise
helfen könnte denn das ist ja ein fall
ein ganz besonders emotional
geschilderte frau karrenbauer aber einer
wie es ihn zu hunderten gehabt
vielleicht zu tausenden in vergangenen
tagen also ich will das 1
ich will das gerne zu sagen dass wir
morgen telefonieren und dass ich da mich
mal schlau macht aber das programm bei
anspricht ist natürlich das was ich
jetzt die letzten tage auch erlebt habe
die menschen sehen im fernsehen es geht
los ich lege die anrufe als war ich mir
auch bundestagsabgeordneter als
abgeordneter die wollen wissen wie ist
das hat jetzt kontakt mit dem landrat
der sagt morgen waren die mobilen teams
los der impfstoff ist gestern gekommen
also der ist jetzt am samstag
angeliefert worden so und es warten alle
darauf und das muss jetzt losgehen und
die alten und pflegeheime das will ich
auch mal sagen wir haben ganz ganz viel
über schulen diskutiert und kitas das
ist total wichtig aber wir haben viel zu
lange nicht hingeguckt was in den alten
und pflegeheim passiert und die trage
schon eine sind die tragischen fälle
sind da die hohen zahlen sind da und
deswegen ist auch so wichtig dass es da
los geht und dass endlich was passiert
jetzt in den einrichtungen ganz viele
unserer mütter und väter unserer
großväter und großmütter sofort volker
bauer leben ja in altenheim aber ganz
viele eben auch nicht die sind zu hause
das heißt eine ganz häufige frage war ja
auch gerade von denen viele zu hause
sitzt na gut jetzt kommen die mobilen
teams in die altenheime aber was ist
eigentlich mit uns die wir nur zu zweit
oder vielleicht alleine zu hause sitzen
das heißt diese antwort ist vielleicht
auf irgendwelchen websites gefunden die
ist aber auf dem land oder bei denen die
zu hause sitzen gar nicht angekommen
das heißt da fehlt es offenbar an ganz
konkreter praktischer hilfe der kinder
ja aber die kommunikation muss besser
werden aber das sind natürlich die dann
auch schnell dran sein müssen aber
erstmal sind alten und pflegeheime sind
jung wir wollen oder antwort haben
wollen eine antwort ich habe auch die
rückmeldung ist die teilweise an
hotlines abgewiesen werden dass man da
keinen info bekommen dass meine ich ja
mit dem chaos das sind alles dinge wo
ich wo ich gebe es zu ich auch gedacht
hatte man hat das jetzt in den letzten
monaten vorbereitet weil dieser punkt wo
es los geht der ist ganz zentral und ich
glaube dann können menschen auch noch
mal drei vier wochen warten aber dann
muss man ihnen sagen dann kommt der
impfstoff dann ist klar und dann seid
ihr dran frau karrenbauer gibt es bei
ihnen jetzt aussicht dass sich das ganze
doch noch zu einem happy end entwickelt
also gibt es neuen impftermin der dann
tatsächlich stattfindet wie ein vater
nein bisher gibt es keinen impftermin
und das große problem wird bleiben dass
er einer der wenigen dort drin ist
die ja die es bisher nicht haben und es
kann natürlich jede minute zu spät sein
also hier geht es auch im leben und
wurde was ich noch mal sagen wollte
grundsätzlich die altenheime wurden
wirklich vernachlässigt man hat menschen
weggesperrt und dessen sind sich viele
gar nicht bewusst man hat diesen
menschen auch die freiheit genommen und
da sitzen menschen die sehr wohl denken
können und sehr gerne über ihr eigenes
leben entscheiden würden
und da wird die tür zugemacht also nicht
verschlossen in unserem heim aber darf
kein mensch mehr raus und ich frage mich
jeder kläger kann rein gehen auch in ein
quarantäne aus warum kann ich als
tochter oder all die menschen die ihre
angehörigen so gerne gesehen hätten auf
dem weg vielleicht in den tragischen tod
begleitet hätten warum ist das
verhindert worden warum können wir nicht
in einer vollen montur zu unseren
menschen gehen die wir lieben und sagen
ich begleite dich auf diesem weg oder
ich sehe dich und gebe dir das gefühl
ich bin an deiner seite
das ist für mich das tragischste was
gesamtdeutschland betrifft so kann das
für die ängste angehörigen ich weiß von
ihnen frau karin bauer sie waren sehr
sehr häufig fast jeden tag bis mitte
dezember dann bei ihrem vater wäre es
gewesen das heißt die selbe
schutzausrüstung zumindest in aller
engsten angehörigen zur verfügung zu
stellen damit halb besuch stattfinden
kann in altenheim
ich glaube wir hätten da viel stärker am
anfang hingucken müssen wie man das
hinkriegt ich das tragischste was ich
mal hatte war ein brief einer einer frau
die mir aus dem wahlkreis geschrieben
hat und die gesagt hat ihr vater sitzt
ein alten und pflegeheim und der hat
eigentlich nur noch einen wunsch seine
enkelkinder zu sehen ja und das auch so
und dass das hat mir das herz gebrochen
sodass und ich glaube wir waren am
anfang viel zu groß und wir hätten uns
vielmehr gedanken machen müssen wie wir
den zugang auch gewähren können mit
welchen regierte mittlerweile geht es ja
an vielen stellen durch den lockdown
jetzt noch mal waren verschärfte
maßnahmen auch durch die feiertage aber
es muss wieder möglich sein dass die
menschen die in den alten und pflegeheim
sitzen dass die menschen treffen und
dass die besuch bekommen
die sozialen kontakte sind mit das
wichtigste für alte menschen ich weiß
nicht ob sie frau karrenbauer klingbeil
frau leutheuser dass die tage
aufgeschnappt haben ich glaube es kann
ein silvester der tweet eines früheren
sehr hochrangigen mitarbeiters aus dem
gesundheitsministerium lutz stroppe
staatssekretär dort und er beschrieb
dort einen ganz privaten fall nämlich
von seiner ebenfalls 88 jahre alten
mutter sagt nämlich in diesem
seniorenheim in frankfurt da seien eben
weniger impfdosen als bewohner und jetzt
werde erst einmal ausgelost sozusagen im
bingo frau leutheuser in altenheim die
die glück haben die sind durch die pech
haben heraus also das ist natürlich
genau das was eigentlich nicht eintreten
darf dass es ausgewählt bricht
priorisiert wird das war von anfang an
klar weil eben nicht für alle altenheime
und ich will aber genauso sagen für alte
menschen über 90-jährige in häuslicher
pflege die ja auch nicht raus können wo
aber ein ambulanter pflegedienst kommt
und er geht von haus zu haus und auch
eine große gefährdung da ist dass man
darauf sich nicht konzentriert hat es
hat in der vergangenheit viel zu spät
mal die überlegung gegeben wie kann ich
mit ffp zwei masten kostenlos in diese
einrichtung überhaupt meine hilfe gehen
hat man über kosten hin und her
bestritten
man hätte sehr viel mehr an ausstattung
machen können im letzten jahr unabhängig
vom impfen und ich denke so ein verlosen
ist ja also das allerletzte
natürlich ist so das alter und die die
gebrechlichkeit die anfälligkeit ein
kriterium man kann nicht alles in
regelungen schreiben wie das dann auch
gerade in so einer situation vor ort ist
aber ich glaube das führt zu einer
solchen verzweiflung dass man alles tun
muss damit wirklich mit aller macht ins
dorf dorthin kommt und ich hoffe dass
man von biontech die reproduzieren in
marburg wo anders an sich stellen dass
man da jetzt oben
dran ist und schon die nächsten
millionen bestellt hat in deutschland
die millionen impfdosen
jetzt kann man den altenheim
wahrscheinlich die wenigsten vorwürfe
machen die sind einfach im moment
teilweise überfordert mit dieser
situation aber es gibt eben zu viele
dinge die nicht laufen zu wieder dinge
die nicht klar geregelt sind wie stellt
man das jetzt schnellstmöglich ab vor
allen dingen diese unerträglichen
zustände in den heimmärkten bei was
könnte das müsste das rezept und also
konkret braucht man jetzt mehr impfdosen
also das ist natürlich ist das verlosen
furchtbar und bewussten aber in der tat
es muss priorisiert werden verlosen
finde ich dass das gehört sich nicht
aber natürlich müssen jetzt diejenigen
vor ort in den landkreisen die die
impfdosen haben müssen jetzt entscheiden
welcher reihenfolge sie vor das haben
wir im parlament diskutiert gibt eine
verordnung von ihren sparen wir müssen
jetzt gucken wir nach produzieren können
wir müssen gucken dass die hotlines
laufen also das ist verbindliche
informationen gibt das muss jetzt
schritt für schritt gemacht werden ich
find auch da muss man jetzt gucken wir
wussten immer es gibt einen engpass am
anfang es wird dann mehr
wir hoffen dass jetzt noch nicht weiß
weil das problem ist doch dass sie sehr
großzügig waren bei der benennung dieser
gruppen dass sie so sehr pauschal gesagt
haben leute mit vorerkrankungen oder
erstmal über 80-jährigen gibt aber sehr
sehr viele über 80-jährige in
deutschland bei wm fängt man dann andere
die am ort müssen genau diese schwierige
entscheidung treffen genau wissen dann
nämlich nochmal priorisieren und
entscheidungen treffen um die sie
beziehungsweise die politik sich
gedrückt aber jens spahn hat doch heute
die zusage gemacht bis ende januar
sollen alle bewohner von alten- und
pflegeeinrichtungen sollen geimpft sein
das ist finde ich etwas womit man jetzt
auch klar kommunizieren kann das muss
jetzt kommuniziert werden wenn wir das
schaffen ist das schon mal ein guter
schritt dann müssen wir uns um
diejenigen kümmern die auch risikogruppe
sind die zu hause sind sie haben von die
fälle besprochen es geht ganz viel auch
um das personal ich finde das
medizinische personal das personal in
den alten und pflegeeinrichtung muss
auch sehr schnell geimpft werden und
dann muss man für vorgehen aber das was
wir als politik jetzt gerade machen
können ist eine klare kommunikation aber
ich sehe die aufgabe vor allem jetzt da
drin und dann muss am dienstag bei der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz nochmal
drüber geredet werden können wir noch
etwas tun um mehr impfstoff in den
nächsten wochen auch wirklich zu
bekommen können wir was tun und ich gebe
mich nicht damit zufrieden dass ein land
wie deutschland wo dieser impfstoff ja
sogar erforscht wurde
stolz drauf sein ja dass wir auf einmal
diejenigen sind die viel weniger in der
lage länder da gebe ich mich nicht zu
verlieren und tyler und ich möchte dass
am dienstag wenn die da zusammensitzen
die ministerpräsidenten mit der
bundeskanzlerin dass dann noch mal
überlegt wird was kann man tun und ich
sage ihnen am geld wird das nicht
scheitern also jede woche die wir im
lock down sind kostet uns auch
milliarden ich glaube 4 milliarden hab
ich mal gelesen und das geld gebe ich
lieber für die impfstoffproduktion aus
als dass wir länger lockdown sind und
länger irgendwie leuten sagen bleibt zu
hause
diese zusage frau karrenbauer das bis
ende januar jeder in den altenheimen
dann geimpft wird
glauben sie daran ich glaube daran aber
was nutzt was nutzt es bis ende des bis
ende januar wir haben den dritten januar
das sind mehr als drei bei und in dem
moment könnte können viele viele
menschen gestorben sein
hier ist ja wahr die diskussion
aufgetaucht ob man den stoff den man
gerade zurückhält vielleicht doch fremd
er laut aber hatte das glaube ich mal
angesprochen ob man das nicht jetzt
verändern könnte und wenn man eine
zusage hat dass der nächste impfstoff
doch zum 18
dann diese erst nehmen stoßen dann für
den 2 wir machen gleich mit ihnen weiter
von carmen bauarbeiten schon mal hier in
der runde stelle ich fest bei frau
leutheuser bei ihnen auch herr klingbeil
dass wir alle möglichkeiten noch
momentan sind die bundesländer
angewiesen nur die hälfte der impfstoff
in sie haben zuvor immerhin dass er
einfach nicht genau aber seither weitere
möglichkeit wäre ja noch mal sagen ist
auch das hat der peter tschentscher aus
hamburg gesagt
die frage kann man eigentlich also ich
bin kein mediziner ja deswegen klingt
das jetzt vielleicht sehen in
wissenschaftlich aber aus einer aus
einer dosis die gerade mit fünf
impfungen ja kann man da nicht sogar
sechs oder sieben vielleicht was man das
muss aber die europäische kommission
jetzt frei geben das muss erlaubt sein
das hat auch versicherungswesen sowie
die europäische kommission sind es jetzt
die hälfte der zuschauer kommt aber wird
sowieso nur die europäische kommission
macht die zulassung und ich war also hat
ihren sparen hat die bundeskanzlerin
haben die die letzten tage schon bei
frau von der leyen sturm geklingelt und
haben gesagt mach endlich die freigabe
dafür dass wir sechs oder sieben
impfungen aus einer dose macht ist aber
dass ich so richtig verstehe ich
verstehe dass herr klingbeil dass sie
sagen aber jetzt macht frau karrenbauer
den vorschlag und sagt kommt lasst uns
doch die duh
die da sind wir impfen jetzt sagen sie
ja ist eigentlich von dem wasserschlauch
nachricht wirkt und dann beruft man sich
dann muss die betreiberin des
altenpflegeheims sich auf die vorgaben
der kommission berufen also na ja klar
europa muss doch nicht automatisch
langsam sein europa kann war auf
langsame und es ist mir zu langsam und
es muss geklärt werden und wir haben
starke politiker in unserer
bundesregierung werde eine starke
bundeskanzlerin wir haben die
kommissionspräsidentin frau von der
leyen
die sollen alte druck machen das ist
jetzt geht das ist nicht unmöglich noch
mal wir sind
wir sind ein starkes land und wir können
das durchsetzen den europäischen weg
aufzugeben hielt sich aber für falsch
frau karrenbauer man hätte schon viel
eher tschuldigung klären können ob man
das darf ob man aus einer ampulle zwei
produkte dosen
das kann ich als neue idee ergeben werde
ich habe gehört dass das schon passiert
dass das nicht mein problem angeblich
von zulassung sein soll
nur wenn sie mehrere ampullen als einmal
aus 57 oder so mischen vom selben
impfstoff das ist dann nicht von der
zulassung gedeckt und da wird von der
leyen auch nicht sagen können das ist
dann wir die europäische medizinisch
noch mal ganz kurz kann es nicht ganz
begreifen
in den letzten tagen geklärt hat dass da
das gesundheitsministerium trotz
feiertage aber mal wirklich nicht nur am
telefonieren sondern am chatten und
zoomen ohne ende
mit der europäischen zukunft würde heute
dass der relative ministerium erwartet
das ist eine relativ einfache frage doch
eigentlich dürfen wir die erstimpfung
auch wird dürfen wir die zweitimpfung
auch schon woanders als erste impfen so
dass der impfstoff der halt im keller
liegt können wir den erstmals komplett
verbraten
das ist eine relativ einfache frage und
da müssen wir trotzdem wieder auf
brüssel warten bis die frage zu klären
ist das kann man das kommt mir doch
einfach entscheiden
ich glaube ich nicht also stellt sich
doch also ich habe auch den jetzt gehts
durcheinander ganz kurz vor karrenbauer
tschuldigung abgesagt der nachgeordneten
stoff jetzt der nachkommen soll das ist
doch auch einer von bei und deckt die
nächste chance kommt
von bayern check deswegen habe ich jetzt
die frage nicht verstärken ob sich diese
eng stoffe miteinander weißen oder
miteinander verträglich sind
wir klingen weil das gerade gesagt hat
sondern die dosen sind da und wenn man
zusagt dass am 8 oder am 18
die nächsten dosen kommen und zwar von
bayern check gibt sich doch für mich
oder ergibt sich für mich nicht warum
man das jetzt nicht verhelfen kann
bei den anderen dosen er schon auf dem
marsch sind oder auf dem wege sind müsse
man kriegt für mich auch logisch aber
der liga ist eine ansage aus dem
gesundheitsministerium geben
das hat markus söder frauen gesagt die
klare ansage aus dem
gesundheitsministerium als auf
bundesebene
ihr müsst die hälfte zurückhaltend mir
ist bisher nicht bekannt dass darüber
nachgedacht wird das aufzugeben wenn das
aufgegeben wird dann kann das so gemacht
werden die frau karrenbauer das gerade
sagt aber momentan müssen sich die
länder natürlich an die vorgaben von
ihren spahn hat eine frage zum abschluss
habe eine frau karrenbauer bei
verzeihung noch einmal frau leutheuser
basic hat schon gebrochen haben ja ich
wollte nur sagen in großbritannien hat
man die abstände vergrößert auch mit
biontech zwischen der ersten und der
zweiten impfung und der gründer von bei
und exakt ja die 21 tage oder zwei
wochen sind nicht fix davon hängt die
wirkung der 95 prozentigen grades nicht
ab das ist doch ganz schnell zu klären
und dann ist es überhaupt kein problem
eben mehr erst impfungen zu machen und
die zweit impfungen dann ein bisschen
nicht lang aber ein bisschen
hinauszuschieben und dann könnte man
diese härtefälle vermeiden wie frau
karin beiers geschildert hat wirklich
mal was mir nur wichtig ich bin kein
experte deswegen mache ich mir auch
nicht an jetzt entscheiden zu können wie
gut geimpft werden kann oder nicht dafür
gibt es viele leute aber unsere kurze
debatte hier zeigt doch gerade schon
wenn sich jetzt die richtigen leute an
einen tisch setzen und wenn man darüber
nachdenkt und zwar schnell und nicht
jetzt monatelang wochen lang sondern
schnelle entscheidung dann wird man das
alles noch beschleunigen können da bin
ich mir total sicher und das ist das was
ich erwartet und das muss dienstag bei
der tat das fatale ist ja dass all diese
fragen offenbar gar nicht ausdiskutiert
sind das ist ja das erstaunliche und
fatale nach so langer zeit
abschlussfrage frau karrenbauer
wir alle drücken
natürlich ihrem papa die daumen dass er
sich eben obwohl so viele corona fälle
um ihn herum sind in dem heim sich nicht
ansteckt tapfer bleibt gesund bleibt
aber auch vom kopf her was haben sie dir
das gefühl wie geht er damit um wie
lange hält er das noch durch ohne
impfung einigermaßen einigermaßen gut
gelaunt na ja im moment hat der husten
und ich habe ihn heute müssten mittel
gebracht oder vorbei gebracht die dann
umgebracht wurden
erstere getestet er ist nach wie vor
negativ also wo er sich damals ein
gesamt ab weiß ich nicht aber was ich
merke ist dass er sehr abbaut weil er
die einsamkeit kaum erträgt war das ein
sehr geselliger mensch ist menschen
liebt und warte nicht gerne liebt und
das macht eben jetzt seit 21 tagen sehr
zu schaffen ich bin der rote faden in
seinem leben der jeden tag mit ihm zwei
stunden raus gegangen bin und ich denke
das wird vielen vielen anderen menschen
in den heimen genauso gehen
wer zu lange alleine ist der hat halt
das problem dass da was ganz anderes zu
greift nämlich auch depressionen und das
merke ich auch in meinem vater während
trauriger wird und schwächer wird
danke herzlich für die schilderung die
glaube ich ganz vielen in deutschland
aus dem herzen spricht frau karrenbauer
ich will noch einmal zu dem nächsten
großen thema diese woche über dieses
diskutieren nämlich die verlängerung des
löw teams hecking war jetzt einmal ohne
politiker denken strategisch wenn sie es
zuhause erd und worauf stellen sie sich
persönlich ein wie lang wird das ganze
dauern mit dem look da und müssen sich
ab ein grundsatz und der ist wir
brauchen jetzt eine wir brauchen jetzt
etwas was langfristig trägt formal sehr
offen gesagt dass ich im november davon
ausgegangen bin wenn man diesen november
locker und macht drei wochen und alles
zu dann sind die zahlen wieder so dass
man dass man da vernünftig mit klar
kommt und das war ein irrglaube dass das
da habe ich auch eine falsche analyse
gehabt und jetzt bin ich sehr unsicher
ich glaube aber wir müssen jetzt über
zwei drei wochen das müssen die
ministerpräsidenten entscheiden wir
brauchen auf jeden fall diese
verlängerung ich tippe mal bis ende
januar wird es sein und dann muss man
das wieder bewerten aber wir müssen da
jetzt durch wir müssen jetzt die zahlen
runter kriegen wir müssen gucken anhand
der der inzidenz 'nen auch abwandern
wieder alles zurück gefahren also das
normale leben zurück
aber nicht den fehler machen jetzt zu
früh nachzulassen und dann muss man
vielleicht vor ostern in den nächsten
lockdown und deswegen glaube ich einfach
jetzt geht es wirklich noch mal um diese
kraftanstrengung auf den letzten metern
eines ganz schwierigen marathons den weg
laufen sind es ist nicht lange her aber
mehr als drei wochen her da saß dort der
kanzleramtsminister helge braun und hat
im laufe der sendung gesagt wenn wir mal
drei wochen richtig konsequent dicht
machen dann schaffen wir es dann reichen
diese drei wochen um den wert unter 50
zu kriegen
davon sind wir ja ganz kleiner erweitert
werden weil wenig konsequent fahren also
eher sagte konsequent dann funktioniert
oder weil die regeln nicht befolgt
wurden oder hat er einfach nicht recht
mit sondern ich muss ihnen sagen ich
kenne eigentlich nur menschen die sich
an regeln halten also wenn ich in meinem
persönlichen umfeld auf mich um reiche
wie man silvester gefeiert hat wie man
weihnachten gefeiert hat alle haben sich
an regeln gehalten
und wenn wir nach großbritannien gucken
wo diese mutation des virus jetzt
aufgetauchtes großbritannien ist in viel
härteren locker und als wir das sind und
trotzdem steigen die zahlen und das ist
etwas was mir sorgen macht also obwohl
sich so viele menschen an regeln halten
gehen die zahlen dort hoch und und und
dann schaue ich mir die meldung ansehen
wir haben landkreise die sind weit über
der grenze wir haben landkreise wo die
intensivstation voll sind wir haben ganz
dramatische situation die auf uns
zukommen können wenn die zahlen über
weihnachten über silvester sich falsch
entwickelt haben und deswegen glaube ich
einfach wir sind jetzt gerade weit davon
entfernt zu sagen wir kehren zur
normalität zurückkämpfen ist die
hoffnung impfen ist das was das licht am
ende des tunnels ist dann heute ganz
viel drüber geredet da müssen wir besser
werden aber es ist jetzt noch nicht die
zeit für lockerung das heißt es wird
auch keine zeit sein schule wieder zu
öffnen kita zu öffnen ganz schwierige
diskussion also wirklich eine ganz
schwierige diskussion weil ich die
eltern verstehe die sagen wir wollen
nicht dass unsere kinder dass ihnen was
verloren geht dass schule bildung
verloren geht die hat die haben angst
auch um die wissen stellen ihrer kinder
ich verstehe die eltern die sagen wir
müssen aber die betreuungssituation
klären und trotzdem gibt es ja immer
mehr hinweise darauf dass auch schulen
infektionsherd sein können das in
großbritannien auch in studien
da wird drüber geredet auch morgen im
vorfeld auch der ministerpräsident
konferenz gibt es auch fachgespräch auch
mit wissenschaftlern man dreht sich
man muss eine lösung hinbekommen das was
wir als spd bei der letzten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz gefordert
haben wir dann wenigstens bezahlter
urlaub für eltern die sich um ihre
kinder kümmern müssen dann müssen die
unternehmen den freigeben zehn tage 14
tage eine woche das hat die union
blockiert aber das werden wir uns
nochmal auf die tagesordnung setzen also
man muss dann auch mitdenken wenn man
schulen und kitas zuletzt was ist mit
den eltern und die müssen dann die
möglichkeit auch haben nicht home office
und betreuung zu verbinden sondern die
brauchen dann bezahlten urlaub im moment
natürlich besteht immer die hoffnung
dass bis längerfristig natürlich zu
wissen frau leutheuser jetzt erfährt man
es diese woche dann am dienstag
vermutlich wie es dann nach dem zehnten
weiter geht dann geht ist die nächste
hängepartie bis ende januar und die
befürchtung die große befürchtung dass
das homeschooling dann eventuell
zumindest für bestimmte altersklassen
noch weiter geht das ist echt schwer
erträglich im moment für eltern für
millionen eltern in deutschland
ja es ist eine ganz ganz schwierige
situation und wir müssen uns klar machen
bis ende januar das ist eine sehr sehr
lange zeit da kann man nicht so drüber
weg gehen und sagen ende januar ja da
machen wir jetzt den lockdown das ist in
ordnung wahrscheinlich kann man es nicht
anders machen aber das kann nicht mit
der inneren einstellung passieren und
dann verlängern was im februar genauso
also es muss einfach sehr viel mehr
passieren im bildungsbereich ist es eine
katastrophe dass die letzten im letzten
jahr in sommermonaten überhaupt nicht
die möglichkeiten genutzt worden um sich
besser einzustellen auf
präsenzunterricht und deshalb wird es
bestimmt wechsel unterricht mit auch die
stores unterricht und eben auch mit
einigen in der schule geben aber sehr
schwierig aber man kann das nicht ewig
so perpetuieren nicht nur mit blick auf
die massiven wirtschaftlichen folgen
sondern mit rücksicht auf dem was das
mit den menschen wirklich macht nicht
nur mit denen menschen in alten und
seniorenheim das haben wir erörtert auch
mit jungen menschen auch mit denen
die auch um wirtschaftliche existenz
kämpfen und da gibt es ja auch sehr sehr
viele
und von daher kann es nicht sein dass
man jetzt so sich in einen atmosphäre
begibt das der lockdown das erste
quartal des jahres 2021 bestimmen wird
es muss alles getan werden um ab februar
im gewissen umfang zu versuchen wieder
zu einer begrenzung der beschränkungen
zu kommen was er jetzt schon überall
passiert das geht ja morgen dann los ist
das homeschooling ebene viele schulen
haben sich da mittlerweile darauf
eingestellt aber an vielen schulen
bedeutet homeschooling eben auch das im
grunde kein unterricht stattfindet
werden paar unterrichtsmaterialien rüber
geschickt und im grunde hält da die
schule aber komplett aus würden sie ja
klingbeil erwarten dass die lehrer sowie
ganz viele andere im moment auch
angefangen natürlich bei den
krankenhäusern aber eben beispielsweise
auch müllabfuhr über weihnachten neuer
sonderschichten einlegt eben sich
konzentriert um die schüler kümmern hat
möglicherweise samstags auch unterricht
anbietet digital
ich war ja viel an schulen auch
unterwegs im wahlkreis und da habe ich
schon gesehen dass wirklich viele viele
lehrer echt enormes auf die beine
gestellt haben ja das war der wechsel
unterricht der präsenzunterricht es war
das digitale ich habe bei mir lehrer
erlebt die sind von tür zu von haustür
zu haustür gefahren und haben mit den
schülerinnen und schülern dann auch
geredet und haben kontakt aufgesucht und
das sind die positiven beispiele die wir
haben und das war richtig dass jetzt
alle auch über die feiertage mal
durchatmen konnten nach diesem
anstrengenden jahr und jetzt müssen wir
gucken wie wir starten ob wir
präsenzunterricht zu lassen erst der
sechste klasse abschlussklassen ob das
schon wieder möglich ist das erlaubt ja
auch der beschluss den wir den wir im
dezember hatten oder ob es an anderen
also ob es noch nicht möglich ist das
hängt ja vielleicht auch immer ein
bisschen davon haben in bayern ist die
situation anders als in mecklenburg
vorpommern wenn man sich anguckt
also ich möchte da nicht gerne was
pauschales haben aber es müssen lösungen
gefunden werden das ist mir das wichtige
die zwei sachen ermöglichen das eine ist
eine betreuungssituation die muss
vernünftig sein für die kids und das
zweite ist wir müssen einfach gucken
dass da keine verlorene generell also
kein verlorenes schuljahr produziert
wird ja die müssen lernen können und da
sind wir bei der digitalisierung noch
lange nicht so weit wie ich gerne wäre
und ich hätte mir auch gewünscht dass
halb frau
leutheusser schnarrenberger hat gesagt
dass man das vergangene jahr auch
genutzt hat um noch mehr im bereich der
digitalisierung zu machen und es wird
immer so getan als ob digitalisierung
die zweitschlechteste lösung ist wenn
man das richtig macht dann kann das auch
eine gute lösung sein und ist nicht nur
das aus also das ausweichmanöver
wir müssen lernen dass digitalisierung
ganz zentral und unserem leben ist und
da sind viele schulen leider nichts
passieren das ist natürlich dass wir 20
21 am anfang zumindest dieselben
gespräche führen die wir im sommer und
herbst 2020 geführt haben und die
hoffnung ende 2020 feier dass wir einen
plan dann irgendwie finden dass man den
leuten eine perspektive geben kann jetzt
stehen wir anfang 20 21 genau da wo wir
es gibt viele schulen die vieles getan
haben also das will ich auch mal sagen
ich kenne wirklich könnten jetzt kennen
sie alle nicht in der lüneburger heide
genug schulen wo man auch in den
sommerferien zusammen gesessen hat wo
man an konzepten gearbeitet hat klar die
positive beispiele gibt sie gibt es auch
jeder gehen und las er vielleicht sollte
das stärkt natürlich kann die politik
nicht aus der verantwortung lassen ich
sofort dabei ich habe mich auch über
manches gewundert was in ländern
passiert ist aber trotzdem gibt es viele
positive beispiele wo man sich auf den
paar leute häuser noch einmal dazwischen
ja ja aber man braucht doch eine
funktionierende plattform für das
homeschooling und das ist in bayern
er selber ist leider nicht mehr da ein
desaster die gibt es nicht da ist jetzt
die deadline der zehnte januar
man weiß schon man wird es nicht wieder
nicht hinbekommen und da findet eben
kein guter distanz unterricht statt
nämlich in die stores unterricht wo der
lehrer an wirklich in der klasse steht
und richtig die schülerinnen und schüler
an ihren bildschirmen aufruft die sich
einbringen fragen stellen richtig
kompletter unterricht vollkommene
fehlanzeige
bei allem tollen engagement von elf von
einigen lehrerinnen und lehrern die
versuchen irgendwie sich zu behelfen
sowas kann nicht zustand 2021 sein und
da ist eindeutig ein versagen der
regierenden in unterschiedlicher form
aus den letzten jahr zu konstatieren
da kommt man nicht drumrum frau
leutheuser frau karin bauer erklingen
ball zum ende dieser sendung will ich
ihn nach dem wir ganz viel über die
alltagsprobleme alltagssorgen alt
diskutiert haben noch ein paar fälle
zeigen von denen die sagen ist mir
ziemlich egal was ihr von lockdown redet
und wie ihr euren lockdown erlebt für
uns ist kein lockdown wir verreisen
[Musik]
countdown zum jahreswechsel 20 21 in
dubai brüllende menschenmassen keine
abstände und keine masken
hier wird gefeiert was das zeug hält und
das obwohl zuvor wer auf die großen
silvester-party wollte sich ein bändchen
organisieren musste schon der weg zur
party location dichtes gedränge
hier aber immerhin noch mit maske
und auch bei den privat partys ging es
ordentlich ab und für diese ließen sich
vor allem die frauen zuvor etwas gutes
tun
bild traf unternehmergattin sandra eben
mit ihrer freundin claudia cruse im
schicken penthouse an der dubai marina
ja ich war lange genug zu hause jetzt
und habe mich testen lassen haben
natürlich alle regeln eingehalten als
silvester sind immer emotionen ich
wollte jetzt einmal raus gehen und noch
mal feiern
szenenwechsel eine suite im luxus-hotel
wie marriott marquis hotel dubai hier
feiert der berliner unternehmensberater
david ray eine prix party mit seinen
freunden
stößchen here's 11 hier wird ganz
offensichtlich die zeitgenossen bin ich
jetzt zurück nach deutschland fahren ist
dieser urlaub 18 tage quarantäne wert dh
wäre dann wahrscheinlich bei der familie
14 tage gesehen
und das ist eben halt der werbetherapeut
dafür dass ich hier reden aber zu hause
bleiben es bei diesen aussichten
sicherlich die schwierigere option ja
und werden uns in dieser woche nochmal
der lockdown hier in deutschland
verlängert wird ist mein kollege john
puthenpurackal jetzt dort wo sich
tausende deutsche auch von dem lockdown
entledigt haben nämlich dorthin geflogen
sind und sagen kein bock auf locker und
wir feiern zum beispiel in diesem
beachclub
die wichtigkeit befinde mich hier im
cockpit klappt auf der blue water einen
einer der angesagtesten mit klatsch auf
der insel und auch tatsächlich einer der
hotspots wo viele deutsche
ich habe zum beispiel hat dass du das
ruhrgebiet kindes wir befinden uns hier
auf einen rand des landes in paris
nachdem neuer bis jetzt hat die deutsch
gesprochen
einige haben uns auch wieder erkannt es
wird getanzt
aber es wird ja auch die regeln beachten
tatsächlich als security and die ganze
zeit zwischen diesen einzelnen stück
zwischen einzelbereichen und mitte dass
die gäste entsprechend dort bleiben und
wenn sie diesen bereich mundschutz
verlassen
wir haben natürlich auch mit ein paar
kästen gesprochen und gefragt was macht
ihr hier mitten während eure freunde und
ihre familie zu hause sind die ganz
klare antwort die betreiber wir haben
keine lust auf lotter und wir wollen das
leben feiern
ja wir alle haben keine lust auf lockten
entging weil aber es gibt halt die die
das kleingeld haben und sich aus dem lot
verabschieden können ja ich drücke ihnen
die daumen dass sie gesund bleiben und
dich vielleicht das ist ganz hilfe am
malen praktikum auf eine intensivstation
zu machen und sich mal anzugucken was
hier in deutschland gerade passiert man
mit pflegekräften zu reden die sich seit
monaten rund um die uhr für für die
solidarität in diesem land wirklich
bemühen und anstrengen und alles geben
und ja natürlich keiner von uns hat lust
auf lockdown aber es ist jetzt eine
kraftanstrengung und dann müssen alle
mit dabei sein und ich finde so ein
verhalten egoistisch ich sehe das ja
auch die ganzen fußballer die jetzt
irgendwie nochmal schnell irgendwie in
dubai sonst irgendwie sind wir alle
werden glaube ich gerne in der sonne
oder im skiurlaub aber das gehört zur
solidarität ist gut zum miteinander dazu
dass uns dies einmal zusammenreißen und
dann ist mir wichtiger an den alten und
pflegeheim zu denken als jetzt und wie
an die sonne zu denken und ich glaube
das ist die verantwortung der wir alle
nachgehen können und mit all den man
auch in diese menschen errichten muss
frau leutheuser was fällt ihnen dazu ein
keinen bock auf locker und zählt jetzt
nicht
ja also natürlich wir alle wollen gerne
raus und kontakte haben aber mit no bock
auf etwas kann man ja nicht durch so
eine party
wie kommen das geht einfach nicht und
was ganz wichtig ist es darf durch solch
ein verhalten auf keinen fall eine
gefährdung für andere eintreten
das heißt wenn die reisenden
zurückkommen müssen die in quarantäne
gehen es ist ganz schwierig das zu
kontrollieren dass das auch wirklich
eingehalten wird und das ist ganz ganz
entscheidend weil wenn man von
irgendeinem ort dieser welt kommt ohne
gefahr ist dass man mit einer infektion
kommt muss man am ankommenden flughafen
sofort einen pcr-test machen und dennoch
natürlich in quarantäne und das muss
ganz eng massig erfolgen weil es kann
nicht sein dass durch ein einmaliges
silvestervergnügen mehr menschen in
deutschland gefährdet werden wo
karrenbauer was fällt ihnen dazu ein
oder völlig ohne worte an der stelle
nein es geht mir genauso ich sehe das
ganz genauso und ich finde das ganz
schwierig ich würde so gerne eine
bessere idee wie wir alle zusammenhalten
denn im moment begegnet man doch sehr
vielen leuten die die ellbogen raus
vaart und sage ich ich ich und ich würde
mir sehr wünschen weil ich auch selber
so nicht so sehr an die regeln halte und
meine umfeld eben auch dass wir das dass
wir diesen kraft an
diese kraftanstrengung dass wir das
gemeinsam schaffen weil wir wollen alle
gemeinsam zurück ins leben und ich hoffe
einfach dass ich ja dass ich viel mehr
leute dran halten und nicht die einen zu
hause sitzen und sagen ich gebe treffen
niemand und die anderen gegen chile auf
leider wenig verständnis danke für die
spannende diskussion heute auch mit
ihnen frau karrenbauer mit frau
leutheuser-schnarrenberger und herrn
klingbeil herzlichen dank dafür fürs
mitmachen so jung im neuen jahr danke
ihnen ein dankeschön und wir sind so was
lesen sonntag wieder 14 hier live bei
bild danke
[Musik]